I have the pleasure of doing the last
presentation with my colleague Brian
kaze and we're going to be talking about
Yale external app pilots that we are
conducting and and yeah so just to kind
of give a little bit of background Lukas
kind of touched upon it earlier we moved
from Sakai which was called classes v2
over to canvas this is the second full
academic year that we have been on
canvas as a university and one of the
reasons why we moved to canvas is
because of its ability to be extended
and have it provides the framework so
that third-party vendors and developers
can develop tools that can plug into
canvas and extend the function the core
functionality of canvas beyond what it
can do there are definitely different
ways that tools can be installed within
canvas it can be installed kind of
globally so that all courses within
canvas can use the tool it can be
installed at a school level so if a
professional school buys our tool that's
specific to their group it can be
installed just for that school and it's
also that we also have the ability to
install tools at the course level which
may be for something that is license
based and we only have a small number of
licenses so it get installed only on a
course-by-course basis any tool that we
do install into canvas must be vetted to
ensure that it is accessible and to
ensure that any student data that might
be passed through it or to it is
protected and secure currently we are in
the middle of several pilots which I'm
going to go into details but I just kind
of listed them out here and we do have a
few successful pilots that we will talk
about as well but I'm just going to jump
right on in the first one is grade scope
which is Natalia described very well
this morning so I won't go into too much
detail but in case you came in late and
happen to miss that session it is a tool
that is used for grading it is it was
built primarily to assist with grading
of paper materials like worksheets and
things that faculty have created and
what happens is the instructor will take
their a clean version of their homework
Simon scan it in and they can identify
within that paper an outline of where
they expect students to be writing in
their answers and based on where those
markings are indicated when the student
submissions are scanned in grade sculp
will split up the student submissions
based on where you have identified
within your outline where question 1
would appear versus question 2 and so on
and so forth with that once they're
scanned in there the instructors have
the ability to set up rubrics to
determine how many points they're going
to add or subtract based on different
criteria that the students have
submitted in their answers and those
rubrics are shared amongst multiple
graders so if you have a bunch of
teaching fellows that are supporting you
they can all see how it's scored and and
it will also for those questions that
can be auto scored it will use those in
auto score all the answers there is
definitely an option for student
allowing students to do it or you can
collect all the papers and you can scan
them as the instructor one of the great
benefits to doing this doing your
grading through this tool is you will be
able to see statistics on your normally
just handed in papers statistics that
you wouldn't normally probably get
because you're just sifting through
papers so that's another added benefit
to using great scope another one of our
continuing pilots is Nobel which is a
discussion board tool which is a little
bit more enhanced than what is available
in canvas inherently note Bowl has two
distinct features the first feature is
called the bulletin and the bulletin is
just a tool that is provided in your
course navigation bar and it is
typically used as a as an FAQ area where
students can just post general questions
and students and instructors can reply
to those instructors do have the ability
to post and pin certain questions or
comments that they want to appear at the
very top so there is that ability to pin
things
and there also is added functionality to
allow students to post anonymously to
the bulletin board this is truly
anonymous instructors and students
cannot tell who posted it so it allows
students to maybe feel a little bit more
comfortable about asking a question that
they might feel could get them made fun
of if their name was attached to it or
or otherwise they might just not ask it
because they're afraid of having their
name touch to it so there is the ability
to post or you can post with your name
it's optional whoever's posting can
choose whether or not they're anonymous
or not additionally there is the
functionality that allows people to like
comments so students can like each
other's answers but the benefit here is
that instructors can also like them and
when an instructor likes them it puts a
little green indicator next to it to say
the instructor has endorsed this answer
so that can be super helpful if you want
to provide a a community feeling where
students can answer each other's but you
also want to be able to say but this is
really the right answer and this is what
you should go by so that edit feature is
helpful for that the other half of note
Bowl is it allows you to have graded
assignments essentially the assignments
look very similar to the discussion
board but it does provide a column in
the gradebook and you can grade based on
these right now I'm looking at a student
view of the assignment here and one of
the great things about this tool is the
instructors can set requirements for the
discussion boards and those requirements
could mean that you are saying you must
post at least one original post and you
must comment on at least two others and
with those requirements the students can
easily see what the requirements are and
whether or not they've met those so you
can see on this one they have submitted
an original post which meets that
criteria but they have only submitted
one comment to another student and
they're not quite there yet so students
can easily see whether or not they have
fully completed their assignment on the
instructor view the instructors do get
this little dashboard where they get a
summary of what has been happening
within this discussion the summary
includes a count and tally of how many
original posts the students have
made how many comments they've made to
other students and if you do have
requirements it will indicate for you
whether or not that student has met your
requirement additionally through this
tool if you click on that little
magnifying glass for a student it will
open up a little view so that you can
see all the posts for that individual
student so it quickly takes you directly
to the post for that student and it does
have indicators for looking for their
original post versus looking for
comments so you can flip in between
those on that view the next of our
continuing pilots is a tool called play
posit which is a tool that overlays on
top of videos to allow you to put
self-quizzing and self check questions
on top of your video the benefit to this
tool is it does pause the video at that
moment and it will not allow the
students to move beyond that point until
they have completed the question so this
is a way to ensure that students are
getting through to the end of the video
and actually watching it and you can
actually gauge how much they've
understood while doing it there are
multiple different question types there
are there's the ability to insert web
pages as well and you can also just put
reflective pauses like if you want to
say in the next three minutes be sure to
look out for XYZ you can just kind of
stop them and make them just read that
really fast before they move on so
there's a lot of options for using that
tool another one of our continuing
pilots is turn it in and turn it in is a
tool that allows you to evaluate the
originality of a submission by a student
when you as an instructor create an
assignment you do have the option
whether or not you want to turn on this
tool or not and if you do turn it on for
an assignment when you go into your
gradebook area each student will receive
a little score checker and it will have
a color indicating how much of the
submission is original and not if you
click on that indicator it will take you
directly to the report where it will
show you a numerical grade of how well
that that submission matches against
things and you
also do have filtering options to say if
you see something that is in quotes
ignore that because I'm assuming that's
well cited so you do have some
flexibility in determining what is
included within that score one of our
completed pilots is voicethread voice
that we are moving forward with
voicethread is another sort of
discussion type tool that allows you as
the instructor to create they call them
voice threads and you put in media
artifacts it can be a picture it can be
a video you can put up a PowerPoint or a
document and when the students open up
that artifact they get the ability to
provide comments on that item those
comments can be text comments they can
record their voice speaking the comments
and if they don't have a microphone for
their computer they can actually use
their phone to call in the comment or
they can use their webcam and they can
record themselves with video to to post
comments there are other multiple ways
of using this but I'm rapidly eating
through our time and want to make sure
that we have time for Bryce thank you
all for coming so I'm just going to talk
about just two additional successful
pilots the first one you're probably
familiar with since we've been using it
today is poll everywhere and so we
started we had traditionally supported a
system called turning-point which maybe
are familiar with it used physical
clickers and we wanted to kind of relook
at the polling landscape and see what
was available and so we kind of tested
poll everywhere quickly rose to be kind
of the prominent one we wanted to look
at and so among many advantages that we
find are the extent the extended list of
question types so today you've seen
multiple choice being used but because
students can use their laptop a mobile
device respond via text message you can
have free response you can have Q&A you
can do clickable images so see heat maps
on an image where students are touching
you can do surveys so you can bundle
questions together have students answer
a number of questions at the same time
ranked order so if
you want to give them a number of
choices they can put them in their order
of preference and then it takes all that
information and then gives you you know
a top five top ten list of all the
options and then the ability to up vote
so I don't know if you're familiar with
the kind of the reddit style up voting
you can ask students questions and then
they have the ability to upload other
people's responses so it's a good way to
get get an idea of what's the most you
know popular response pressing question
etc and so in terms of the the canvas
integration that's mostly through the
gradebook so there's a very easy course
roster import so you would just log into
your polleverywhere account sync your
course it brings all your students in no
licensing on the student side which is
something that would that we liked so
their barrier to entry is very low and
then if you choose to grade your
questions you can export those grades
back into the gradebook but you're also
able to run reports on all your
questions and if you're using the canvas
integration you can track overall
student participation for any of your
any of your questions a series of
questions at the end of semester you
could take all your polls run a report
on it and then just see every student's
overall participation for the entire
course
oh and so just a couple screenshots here
we have a number of report types so you
can get a lot of information out of it
download them as CSV is a lot of
different ways to visualize that and
then just a little example of the
connection to the LMS you just select
what course you want to use and it
imports that course roster so another
thing that we liked flexible
presentation types so it can integrate
with PowerPoint keynote Google slides
through an extension in Chrome but you
can also just present directly from the
website so if you don't if you don't use
PowerPoint or keynote in the in your
class you can just bring up a poll very
easily via the website go fullscreen and
it's exactly the same experience
as looking through through the
integration so you can also create your
polls on the website so if you're you
know away from your computer or not
working on your presentation and you
think of a great question you can create
the question you know via browser or on
your mobile device and then it's very
easy to insert that into your
presentation so as you saw today you can
create open polls for immediate access
so if you're not interested in tracking
student participation on a per student
basis you can make polls that are open
to everyone
which is what we've been using today so
all they have to do is go to that
response URL and in there right in they
can answer the questions and then as I
mentioned they can respond via mobile
devices web page text message and a
couple examples here of you just insert
the activity and this is on a Mac that
looks a little different on PC of course
but then the slides just go right into
your presentation and so just moving
onto the next next successful pilot is
zoom which a lot of you are probably
familiar with we don't have a poll for
it but how many people use zoom show of
hands yes I'd imagine a lot of people
but if you don't so this is an IPS
supported resource you can go to Yale
that zoomed at us and log in and you
will get your pro account it's a very
handy resource so the ways that we see
it being used in terms of courses remote
collaboration it allows for screen
sharing polling interactive whiteboard
if you're doing like online meetings
bringing in guest speakers is kind of
where we've seen a lot of the main use
that's very easy very high-quality way
to bring in remote speakers into a
course you can just do it from your
laptop no more really needing to go to a
room specifically kitted out with video
conferencing equipment online office
hours if you want to offer times for
students to come to meet with you but
not in person it's great for that
synchronous online course sessions so
for our online courses we see
a lot of use in that and just good
old-fashioned online meetings very handy
but the instant the integration in
canvas allows you to schedule meetings
directly through canvas so this is the
instructor view you would go to the
zooms section and this is already I
believe in everybody's canvas course you
just have to unhide it in your
navigation you can just schedule a new
meeting and it will show you all the
meetings that you have scheduled and
then as far as it's the student view
when they go in and look and zoom they
just see all the meetings they see a
join button they see when the meeting is
supposed to be hosted can be there kind
of like one-stop repository for all
their courses oome sessions there's
going to be a coming improved
integration in canvas which will then
sync that with their their canvas
calendar so they'll be able to see that
in a calendar view as well going on and
just to let you know things that are
coming so for the fall we are starting
to evaluate respondus lockdown browser
which is a separate browser that can be
installed on student machines that works
in coordination with canvas quizzing so
instructors can create secure quizzing
that once the student clicks on it and
opens it it will open up in this browser
that will either restrict them
completely from accessing anything on
the internet or you can actually
determine that certain specific websites
are okay for them to visit but only
those and it will also prevent them from
being able to access other resources on
their computer and it will also prevent
them from copying and pasting off of
your quiz so it does have a lot of
controls for that the other integration
that we're looking into is an
integration with course pres which will
basically allow it so that your if
you're using course pres blogging it
will insert a link for your course press
site in canvas and the canvas roster
will actually control and manage who has
access to your course press blog
additionally we're starting to
investigate the possibility of
integration with office 365 and an
integration with Qualtrics so we're
starting to look at those
but just so you are aware if you don't
already know we have a page on our
website which gives you a quick status
check on any external tools that are
currently installed in or in the process
of being vetted for installation into
canvas and when you go to this website
listed at the top here you will need to
login with your yellow net ID and when
you go in there you'll be able to see
the list of what's in there and you'll
see the little colorful indicators
showing where it is within the process
and if you see an item that says that's
installed or or something that you're
interested in using if you click on that
tool it will take you to a page that
will show you how to get started and
that may mean filling out a form and
requesting access but you can go to this
site and see what is going on in terms
of our external app status if you are
interested in a tool and would like us
to start looking at it in helping get it
installed the process does take a little
bit of time because we need to do these
checks so if you're looking for
something for the Fall we have deadlines
of March 1st for fall so we've kind of
missed that one for right now for spring
we have a deadline of October and for
summer we have a deadline of November
and when you fill out the form which is
linked here it will send us a little
notice to let us know what you're
looking at and then we will schedule a
consultation with you to discuss what
the next steps are and how to get
started with that and so just to kind of
round out this presentation would love
to hear if you are interested in any of
the apps that we've talked about here
today I don't think we need to do
anything else
it's perfect and we do have information
that we have over in the little resource
fair area which is just off here to your
right and we will have the presenters
over there talking about the things that
they have talked about today they will
be at the tables here as well and we
strongly encourage you to come over and
talk to everyone pick up some of the
papers that we have around that give you
more information about what we're what
we're doing so that kind of wraps up
this segment of our lightning talks
I just want to say
quick thank you to everyone who helped
here setting up Julie and Kim for
setting up all the food and Lucas for
starting us off here and particularly to
the team that helped coordinate this the
committee which included Patrick O'Brien
Bryan Paz a Matt Reynolds and Claire on
Cowie and Christine costantino as always
and thank you so much to broadcaster
being here to help record it and make
this so that we can make it more broadly
available